[Musique]
600 m² 28 exposants le village réunion a
été inauguré ce lundi 24 février dans le
cadre du salon international de
l'agriculture porte de versailles à
paris
c'est une fierté pour le conseil
départemental de la réunion bête
présents à ce salon international 2020
et c'est pour nous l'occasion de faire
la promotion de l'agriculture
réunionnaise de faire la promotion de
notre belle île et c'est surtout mettre
en avant l'ensemble des avoirs faire de
nos agriculteurs de nos artisans de nos
transformateurs qui nous ont accompagnés
dans cette belle aventure
une belle vitrine du savoir faire local
l'opportunité pour les exposants de
promouvoir les produits d'exception de
la réunion sur le continent
bonsoir la réunion
au niveau le salon ça passe très très
bien beaucoup de contacts beaucoup de
professeurs qui passent nous voir aussi
sont étonnés que la réunion positive
mais en plus comme ça pas que ce seul
jeu les français ont les propos de ben à
l'occasion de déguster tous les arrange
et de deux pour le quorum évidemment ce
par premier après ça reste très variés
on a le sirop de famille à l'issue du
sucre complet le ghana b il ya la fleur
de sel c'est qui qui marche très bien
ouais tu es beaucoup de contacts qui dès
beaucoup de gens qui prennent contact
avec moi pour pouvoir après évolué après
par des gens qui meurent produits sains
qui veut re distribuer les produits dans
cette épicerie film et dans la médecine
aussi un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
et on peut dire vienne et vous ramène
des
avec sap et ça s'enchaîne s'asseoir
des couloirs bondés de monde un village
réunion qui attire par la diversité de
ses produits très bien g
témoin j'ai donc j'ai apprécié la
réunion on va la mire son intérêt
et moi j'en viens régulièrement ici
parce que j'achète la vanille mûre qui
tient bien que
extraordinaire et je reviens tout en
tout temps sur votre stand g l'ambiance
et les gens surveillant les résultats
sion le charme et où la diversité est
toujours toujours toujours le sourire
c'est merveilleux la réunion j'ai mangé
comment un menu complet traditionnel de
la rhune
c'était parfait je continue à faire la
ronde il ya du miel de recherche et la
canne à sucre qui source a également
fait le déplacement pour représenter en
musique la réunion le public pourra
chaque jour profiter de divers
animations de dégustation encore
d'ateliers culinaires
[Musique]